[Music]
you are Liam
I am Lehman Liam we're Liam he she we
they Liam the Royal Liam that's the name
of this game you don't know that yet
because it doesn't say on the title
screen you don't believe anything if
it's on right in front of your eyes you
are Liam see okay I know my face is like
blocking it but trust me back there you
can see by the I and the A and the M
maybe whatever you can see that the
title of the games you are Liam right
Lexi and don't reveal it they need to
understand
it's so nice to have you here
yeah nice
I've been wanting to have a personal
chat with you for a while a personal
chat
about personal stuff if you I feel you
have some things you want to get off
your chest
that's why I'm here
so Liam wanted to uh my name is
Markiplier
Markiplier uh no thank you I'm good
calm down you are not Liam
yet there Liam oh
finally
[Music]
um
quick
what
wait a minute hold on oh
William
Liam is that you do that I thing again
no not me you
all right you're shy you're shy oh
Liam
Liam
Liam oh lion
not seeing it hey what's up do I blink
only when I'm looking at you is it like
a staring contest that I keep losing
nope I just blink whenever hello
all right
door is locked well that's good for it
there'll probably be a key on that
little shelf when I come back Roundy Roo
again
can't wait for that excite
all right except why look at this I'm a
genius
wait a minute
but where's the door
I gotta go
backwards
is it just using the blinking as a
loading screen to get between things
because that's pretty cool oh
so bright why is
the lens why do I not have any
reflection
oh
have we met before no actually and I
don't want to talk to you
they are
that's what I thought
it's what I thought was that in the
reflection because I did not see that in
the reflection then again I'm not very
observant
and um kind of stupid sometimes whoa hey
what's up Miranda Miranda Miranda
Miranda Miranda your Randa our he she we
they Rand us
now there's no need to be doing that
that is unnecessary I wish you would
stop that and I would wish you would go
away but I understand that you need to
continue it however also screw you
hey you're doing the eyeball thing again
all right goodbye
was that here
doors locked unlikely
or very likely depending on
what I just said it uh wait ah you get
back here
they're being sassy you don't need to be
sassy with me you can be your true self
I don't judge key perfect
hi
why is the light so circular you
'd be beautiful what
was there a seam in the wall
my blinking is really profound I feel
like in my normal day-to-day life I
don't notice that much
I feel like I don't normally notice that
much blinking but this quite blancatated
I don't know why I had to look at that
indentation on the wall it just looks
like a screaming face
oh well oh oh
and that did what exactly
what did it do
nope
also am I walking with a limp I just
noticed about the noise of me actually
moving
it's like I'm at a gallop
I'm just trotting along
so did that do something
do I go backwards was there some reason
for me to go backwards was there a
necessity oh I'm going in baby no
regrets I'm in here I'm I have a
flashlight now I took my eyes a second
to adjust boy big guy all right I ain't
stopping for nobody or nothing I ain't
but hey what is it bottle caps muffins
cookies eat the food don't need to tell
me twice yum yum yum yum
thank you that was delicious I do
appreciate that you're taking care of me
and that that is really special anyway
back away I go
am I gonna grow big and strong like that
tall guy I saw
that'd be really special
hey what are you doing over okay anyway
oh interesting
who was that that's a new friend I
haven't seen that friend before
I don't know if I want to meet that
friend again but I I
didn't expect you to be there huh
so what wasn't that my task already 1105
hope that he didn't reset me all the way
back to the beginning because that would
be
you do that again I dare you I double
dare you I double dare you to do that
again you try that again you try me you
try me you think you could try me right
now you can't try me you can't try
anything you can't do anything you can't
want anything you won't do anything I
know what
that's what I thought [ __ ] walk away
or have a nice day
shut up you're lovely
I'm going in here now
I'm just a dog barking through a glass
window
I dare you
fine
oh you talking [ __ ] no come on do it
again do it do it do it do it I dare you
to do it fine didn't think so
idiot
maroon
it's doing the thing again
I know what you're up to
fully aware of your tricks
wait a minute I thought I saw something
up there
hey we open it
hey
all right well that worked out well yes
we have
we have what yes we have what
Donuts cookies more muffins well that
was low frame right
[Music]
sure up that thing that was chasing me
isn't still gonna chase me
that would be problematic
hi have you ever tried to look out of
your non-dominant eye and that I only
it's a whole new perspective on life
oh
something's different about you
oh
you can't find him I you didn't give me
enough of a chance
I barely even tried
I barely even got to an opportunity
uh-huh oh yeah well thanks for the hint
I couldn't have telled password
mark2702
oh
my God I'm not gonna remember that [ __ ]
where's my phone
take a little selfie here
and now let's take a picture of this
okay
DM's lad
all right
and I got dim's lad
all right James lad
Wham no are you sure you sure about this
all right ten eight nine five two four
six one three seven
I can't even
oh I can't even put in that many numbers
can't put them in numbers d-e-a-i-i-m-s
-l-a-d
let's please
unless this isn't it and it's some kind
of different thing
well I don't know cause I'm stupid
okay it's gone what if I go back one
more
oh
it's there it's gone okay what if I put
it in while it's gone what about them is
blood what if it's not what if it's
minuses you know like 10 minus eight two
negative eight negative
13 negative 15 negative 19 negative 25
negative 26 negative 29 negative 36.
let's try that
nope that would be stupid
I don't know I'm too dumb for this
oh it's duh okay it's supposed to it's
tell me the order of this so it's l
I
a Liam oh Liam is
dead oh
go Liam is dead oh he's dead
yes Liam
wait a minute oh oh
I don't know if I was supposed to do
that but when I see my buddy Liam I just
I gotta give him a big old hug
I just gotta give him a big old hug
let's see all right I owe it I did did I
not do it right was I not supposed to
die there
all right here we go
peek-a-boo uh-huh I see you
and now I'm going away now goodbye
oh really oh no
Nelly
hey Nelly all right Liam sorry
I hope he's not still right behind me
probably not
oh what what
wait a minute holy [ __ ] wait a minute
what's going on here
was with his reality bending
okay oh boy interesting
all right you come here wait whoa wait a
minute where are you
oh where are you how did you get over
there
how
oh [ __ ]
okay so what I think I have to what
Freedom
oh wow look at me look at me I am Liam
I think that was just me screaming not
laughs
that's the stupid name of this computer
thanks to rager not sponsored
anyway that was very fun that was very
very fun very very fun
but as I've said before
[Music]